Marga buyers jet and if
[Music]
if I could throw these are hard to throw
to be perfectly honest here this one
apparently it's a little bit hard at
least that's what the labor the level is
happy okay then well there's the rest of
the level was that necessary
okay oh there I'm dead bye son I'll just
dance for a little bit this son of a
[ __ ] ass tip team there are lots of
balls I'm oh that's jiggly in my butt if
that arrow could not be placed inside my
spine I would be very well this is
normal they're a real pain in this whoa
okay then well now I know the secret
speedy technique well alright then ear a
bow through what do you got I think if I
did this again I might find a different
outcome may be
[Music]
whoa okay you need to go forward I don't
know what that well [ __ ] you are one
creepy ass giant kid spike ball Pro
because the first time I didn't really
record it so yeah the recording messed
up
don't touch the spikes go over here get
away from the wrecking ball and kill
myself
save my child how do you sir um well
this is a precarious situation I'll just
send my regards to the family which is
me
okay now you're dead and one more for
the road can I kill myself
yep
I did it we're all happy now everyone
did good
markiplier spike fall it was actually on
the top of the front page market bar
spike fall it was on the top of the
front page yeah oh god that one's gonna
be hard you want to see this okay
thank you so much candy gonna break oh
that's impossible
[Applause]
ain't good it's gonna be fine Oh
Mogwai obstacle on my absolute favorite
[Laughter]
why do you choose to spear my crotch
yellow region these are all sticking
their landing which I don't like but I'm
much tougher than I that was right in my
dick I'm only slightly bleeding through
oh oh my god how are you doing
don't bash your head on that okay what
in the world man you you are you are a
man of more fortitude than I could ever
imagine and goddamn do you look funny
right now but I gotta be very careful to
not die goddamn it oh oh oh
markiplier Eva Ron save yourselves know
what oh I remember
Eva I did not like it which was not
happy fun times all over the place why
oh okay then god this is just giving me
the creeps I better run from what
what am i running from the kid Oh
alrighty then not exactly what I was
expecting
Thank You Casspi 1405 holy crap markable
our PTO it's like soccer physics oh I
thought I heard the sound of misery and
pain so that's gonna pop my head up just
get more in the face okay up my butt and
wha why [ __ ] all right that's one
sundown I just got to get rid of the
rest by chopping my balls off close
enough
oh this is gonna end well this sucks
got my feet ah in a rather liberal
motion
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye